uh martina i just wanted to ask you
quickly before we let you go about boris
becker uh someone you know incredibly
well uh who's now in prison i'm an
extraordinary fool from grace
yes boris had had some really bad advice
and then he made some really bad
decisions and now he's paying as high a
price as you can i just hope that he'll
be okay and then he'll come out all
right on the other side
my heart goes out to him and his family
he made some really bad mistakes um and
you know he's paying for him dearly so i
just hope he'll be okay it is an
extraordinary situation isn't it i mean
i know boris quite well uh i have a
interview the first interview with his
his wife lily tomorrow actually on this
show uh it's a it's a tragedy for them
obviously a lot of people don't feel any
sympathy for him they think that he you
know he
he did what he did and he committed
financial fraud and he should pay his
price but he was such an idol in the
sport of tennis it just seemed
extraordinary he's now behind bars
yeah i think the first time it happened
i think i don't think it was his fault
as much as it was of his advisors but he
got let off uh because of who he is and
but because of which i think they paid
more attention to what he was doing and
then the second time it happened it
definitely was on him it seems from what
i've been reading
uh he should have been smarter than that
but uh you know he didn't hurt anybody
he was just trying to save his own
property but that doesn't excuse
obviously uh shirking taxes etc so it's
just uh
you know as tennis players we depend on
other people to tell us what's right
what's wrong lawyers uh cpas etc i've
gotten somebody allows the advice over
the years nothing illegal but uh you
know lots lots of money because you
depend on these people to do their job
so you can do yours um not to excuse
what what boris did and again he's
paying dearly and
uh i just hope his family survives it
intact and most of all boris does
because uh yeah this is this is really
rough